-We have to talk about
those boys in the cave, dude.
-Now, these are
the Thai boys in the cave?
-Yes. Did you guys
talk about that at all?
Can you believe that story?
Ask me anything
about that story.
-Oh, are you fully up to date?
-I can't stop reading about that
story, and it keeps going.
-Like, what's happening now?
-Oh, what's happening now?
Oh, only the boys
shaved their heads,
and they're going
into a monastery
to honor the diver that died.
They're going to go
to a monastery now.
-Oh, my God.
-It's the most amazing story.
-How many kids was it?
-That I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I don't read the fine print.
-Well, you're not about,
like, numbers.
You're feelings.
-Yes.
They all got out.
-Yep.
-They had to -- I'm gonna
talk about this forever.
They had to be sedated.
Did you know that?
-No. Before they went --
-I mean, you seriously
didn't know that?
Why didn't you read this story?
-I was so worried it was
gonna have an unhappy ending.
-I'm only talking about it
'cause it was
a happy ending, of course.
I would never talk about it
if it was a sad ending.
-So, they sedated them before
they took them back?
-Yes. They put them to sleep.
They don't even remember
getting traveled in the water.
Can you imagine?
And they were asleep, and
there was a diver next to them
just watching them to make
sure everything was going fine.
And it took hours, dude.
And it was --
The tunnel was like an "S."
So, at one point,
they couldn't -- It's --
-They say that's,
of the letters,
the worst one
for your tunnel to be.
-And -- Wait. Oh!
And the coach
that brought them there...
-Mm-hmm.
-...which, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there was an outcome
where he was not a hero, yeah.
-But he had studied
to be a Buddhist monk
and he taught them
to meditate to conserve energy.
So they all learned
to meditate in the cave.
♪♪ And they lived
off of rainwater ♪♪
Why isn't every --
-I heard the coach --
I did hear that the coach
didn't eat any of his food.
-Yes. He gave away his food.
-Yeah.
-Ugh!
-I mean, I guess you...
-I don't know why you don't talk
about this every night.
Don't do any jokes about Trump.
Just talk seriously
about this story,
'cause it never ends.
-Yeah.
-It's amazing.
-Well, I remember, we were --
A very similar story.
We were working at "SNL"
when the Chilean miners --
-Oh!
-That was another story that --
You loved that story.
-'Cause they all got out.
-Yeah.
-And remember
the Chilean miners?
Ask me anything about
the Chilean miners.
-Well, I remember
there was one Chilean miner
who, like, loved the camera.
Do you remember that?
-He got a little popular.
-And then I think
we wrote a talk-show sketch
where Fred was that miner.
And then the band was,
like, the other 31 miners.
I can't remember what it was.
-Yeah.
And America never saw
that sketch, right?
-No. Didn't see that.
-No, no.
-I think I might
have also written one where
there were 31 miners went in
and 32 came out.
[ Laughter ]
I think that's maybe
all I had, but --
-Was the 32nd miner Horatio?
-Yeah, probably.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He was just a guy
who lived down there.
He lived in a cave and then
he saw that as his chance out.
-That should
have been on the air.
-By the way, you know about what
happened to Horatio today?
Our friend Horatio Sanz.
-What?
-I think he became
an American citizen today.
-[ Gasps ]
Are you kidding me?
-I think that
truly happened today.
Give it up for Horatio Sanz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-America is better for it.
-We'll have to
fact-check that, of course.
-We'll have to have
a party for him.
-Yeah, we have to have
an American party for him.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
-That's great news.
-I mean, it's no Thai boys
in a cave, but it's --
'Cause it's one person.
-No, I would say,
like, if you had to choose,
at a dinner party, what
to bring up,
either Horatio
becoming an American
or the Thai boys,
you would talk about --
-I am not kidding when
I've just been talking nonstop
to people about it,
and it's been weeks now.
-Yeah.
-It's kind of over as a story,
but it's just
beginning...for me.
-You're just starting?
-They're entering
a monastery now.
-Oh, no.
What if they get trapped
in the monastery?
-Trapped in the monastery.
They won't, they won't.
-They won't get trapped?
-They would never.
-And then the divers have to
get them out of the monastery.
'Cause they only -- They're only
comfortable with the divers,
so even though
there's no water...
-They're like,
"You're the man I trust."
That would be --
They've got to check
those doors, make sure they --
-Well, 'cause I believe
most monasteries in Thailand
do have, like,
the hallways like an "S."
-Do you know --
And you know what?
Elon Musk...
-Oh, great. I want to hear this.
Well, Elon Musk
sent a submarine.
-Yeah. Period. The end.
You know the guy that's
always like, "I'll help,"
and it's like -- And he brings
out some stupid tool
or something or,
like, "unclogs your sink,"
by, like, taking it apart?
Like, I used to live above a
bunch of meth-heads in Chicago,
and, one time, they were like,
"We're gonna fix your sink."
And they just took it apart and
they left for like two weeks.
That's what it felt like.
[ Both laugh ]